it's an 80 kill rate even among mice
that were vaccinated it doesn't matter
they vaccinated can they bomb the
university right now yeah bro no but
then the [ __ ] thing's gonna fall but
did the mice have the boosters yeah mice
didn't get the 14 shots they needed
[Music]
researchers at Boston University have
developed a new covid strain with an 80
kill rate oh good news
I'm so proud of our resources
weaker what the [ __ ] is that 80 kill
rate bro we don't be dead that's way
stronger the marketing they've been
marketing that it's it kills me 80
percent
UCLA right I feel like that's crazy at
this point
I'm not saying USC's better but
what what I don't know dude 80 that's
that's hot that's high well they said
they said the original one was crazy and
it didn't seem like 90 two years well
that was yeah they were also 80 lying
about that one see wait so where did
they develop this yeah why do we want to
make [ __ ] that Universe kills people
aren't they the ones that put like pigs
and rats together and also did like
robots that opened doors and [ __ ] they
yeah they did they did wrong isn't that
all up in Massachusetts Boston bruh what
is it busted that's Boston Dynamics
anything busting them out dude pies will
kill you bro it's the same company tea
party that shit's up there yeah that's
true they gotta they got a bad history
they're a richest dude getting handjobs
oh yeah
bro like I was the best I forgot about
that guy so they took they they got this
they extracted the protein from the
Omicron strain and they combined it with
the original one and that's how they got
why what what are you doing this again
wait hold on
you know what let's give them the
benefit of the doubt my guess is they
started with hey let's figure out how to
destroy it and then the guy comes and
goes hey man we're failing but I did
figure out a way to make a 80 kill rate
oh okay okay now let's blast into the
news can we get a press release for this
one bet you won't do it [ __ ] and he's
like oh yeah I'll show you I bet the
goal was to eradicate it but then they
failed and the guy's like but I did find
a way to kill like people 80 of the time
every time
every time more money 80 of the time
yeah we could sell this to China
it doesn't exactly say why they're doing
because I think it's to be assumed that
in trying to study the virus they
created a more [ __ ] potent virus in
trying to see what happens when you do a
b z I never heard of that before where
you [ __ ] like study a monkey and you
create a killer monkey out of it yeah
I'm not sure that that's
true
that's the Planet of the Apes oh I
didn't want to talk about it but low-key
though that's very close yeah it is kind
of close who like regulates some of this
[ __ ] like who says like Boston you can't
let that out or what yeah what if it
like seeps through the little thing or
something that we're all dead it's the
Consultants they they like they talk
about it first these these guys just
have free time or is this something that
they're like all right agenda today
let's make let's kill worse let's kill
everyone they're trying to study it for
the benefit of mankind but through that
one of the results is that oh you know
along the lines of gathering all this
data on these Pages check this page out
holy [ __ ] 80 kill rate for this one yeah
they're gonna get a huge contract Stark
Industries is going to pay them hundreds
of millions of dollars for this they
would never do that because Stark
Industries would never be I don't know
dude because when you when you develop
weapons of mass destruction what's the
best way to do it you just create
something that can kill people through
the common cold yeah sure you know but
isn't that what they said want to tell
more more of the Cure on the other side
you can see the Cure you can sell more
masks because the mask comes you're
killing it oh making money they're
killing it let's start a sanitize our
company right now yeah dude I bet you
it's gonna kill because if you can kill
people with a common cold
like like for instance barbecue if you
gave one of his people the common cold
that would kill 80 of his gang and you
don't you don't go in guns blazing and
then they just die some with some
mysterious disease and no one knows what
it is amazing kind of like weaponizing
smallpox during colonization yeah
the pr would be great because there's no
no government winning covertly your guys
history is cool
what is this
Brian's like kind of like in September
1973 when they use this against 16
individuals
but like uh I think that's a funny thing
that without batting an eye there's like
a very public about wow geez about kind
of
engineering viruses in a lab here but
when it was suspected that the Wuhan
Institute of virology was had anything
to do with the virus originating people
were like that's not possible yeah yeah
that's [ __ ] yo we just made a better
one here in the U.S a very very yes sir
because yeah it depends who makes it it
really depends who makes I mean like we
we made a lot there was an Anthrax
developed in the US it sounds like a us
thing I think I don't know if I didn't
touch my mail for a decade yeah I
remember
allegedly but it you know and that was
made by like old school Monsanto yeah oh
yeah so like we we developed so many
things so when when Chinese people
developed allegedly you know coronavirus
it's like oh well they're just horrible
people
but like we're not just develop
something that a common cold could kill
80 it's just good branding it's almost
like some white Coast biased things I
don't know another term for it but
because it's Boston University yeah
where it's cool yeah yeah no it's not
cool yeah what if it's South Central
Community College
yeah now what you know what's kind of
funny though is like you know because
when the when the Wuhan Institute of
virology news came out it was widely
panned out here they were like no
there's no way it definitely came from
the wet markets it almost sounded like
maybe in a way America was like no oh
they didn't make that we could do a
better one yeah
[Applause]
of an animal there's nowhere they made
it I got mad
they had to have copied you copied I met
you at that point that company was like
no more eight hour shifts we're going
back to 12 hour shifts 20 hour shifts
it's like rather than blame the correct
people America was like no I'd rather
just like not give them the credit of
making something so potent they
supersized there bro yeah exactly like
how could we disguise this oh bad they
eat bats it came from bats like that's
the only one bats are scary yeah it's
the only way they could justify that
another country developed a virus that
was more potent so so what's yeah what's
the [ __ ] point I don't know that's
the thing it's gonna die yeah obviously
it's always been just like the space War
we always want to make sure one step
ahead developing the worst [ __ ]
disease
it's another way to do chemical because
you can mask it you can hide it because
you know one thing with nuclear weapons
that they say is that you know it
destroys infrastructure so when a
country's taking over another country
they don't want to destroy the buildings
right so chemical warfare is the best
thing so killing you not your cable
connection not your Pia to tear yeah but
then like what happens the nukes are bad
obviously uh but they you do both
statement yeah Luke's back you guys want
to talk history
smart words
and kill it bro so you blow up the city
but then then there's the the long
lasting repercussions of it all that
[ __ ] right with the three-eyed mushrooms
and [ __ ]
three
all the
so then say we kill everybody with 80
Boston vid yeah yeah everybody's dead
yeah but that shit's still living yeah
like it's on it's on [ __ ] well it's a
host yeah long enough outside the UV
areas will kill it UV rays and the
bleach yeah but also if you're smart
over probably of course the time every
two three weeks to play I'll die yeah it
doesn't last long because the virus
needs a host yeah it needs a host but if
it kills if it kills everybody too
quickly then it's not necessarily that
good of a virus because it needs another
host right so how fast does it say how
long it takes to kill people no there's
no speed test but there's no directions
yeah there's no instruction manual on
how to use it the way that they got the
80 is they gave it to mice and 80 of
them just oh my god did they say how
quick below that University it doesn't
say how quick blow it up this is so
scary what's up with Boston bro why are
they it's weird it's cold they're grumpy
a lot of pissed off all the time bro
you've been roads are shaky yeah and the
humidity is crazy it's weird they got
stuff like massacres they do wow they do
they got some weird [ __ ] up there the
marathon too right yeah yeah is that the
one you're talking about no there's
other Boston massacres hey you know
what's crazy it's Celtics
Larry Bird it's an 80 kill rate even
among mice that were vaccinated it
doesn't matter see see they vaccinated
can they bomb the university right now
yeah bro no but then the [ __ ] thing's
gonna fall but did the mice have the
boosters yeah they're gonna get the
boosters though yeah mice didn't get the
14 shots they needed
next next week it's gonna come out that
they developed a cure for it next week
is going to be like 85 oh yeah
dude 30. the one Mouse forget to wear a
mask and that's the one that survived
that's the one that survived they were
they were eating Outdoors though right
they were eating Outdoors yeah
definitely there was no AC on there was
no AC on to spread I'm telling you man
no they didn't they came to the food
thing with their mask on took it off as
soon as they sat so in a seated position
it was fine
but did the mice with the mask did they
wear it so that other people don't judge
them yeah because they're afraid that
they're they're social credit score
that's why I wear a mask so that they
don't they don't they all that guy's so
irresponsible he started the chronovirus
and he's not even wearing a mask dude I
remember the last time I wore a [ __ ]
mask and it's great yeah that's because
then you don't hang up people that blame
you
go to go to Walmart I get all the licks
anything like that wear them out so even
though 80 of the mice died they it says
they died with full virtue being
signaled so that's good
[Laughter]
shut the [ __ ] up
medical books yeah I was like what is
that like a [ __ ] biological term
you're too smart aren't you protein
meanwhile it's like 80 is that is that a
lot
80 kill rate
[Music]